welcome back partners in primary care is
senior focused and ready to help
rocky spoke with one of their doctors to
find out how
what is partners in primary care just
kind of introduce people
to you guys well partners in primary
care is the senior focused primary care
practice
that just opened here in las vegas we're
opening
six locations before the year is out and
two more in the early
part of 2021. so our clinics right now
are in spring valley
fremont street north rainbow south
rainbow
south nellis and southeastern and the
two locations that will be opening
in early 2021 will be henderson
and west craig awesome so covering the
valley
that's great and what does senior focus
care actually mean define that for us
well people over 65 have they're in a
different phase of their lives
and they have different needs and what
we are designed to do is become a
partner with our patients
not just in physical health but in
mental health
in social health and all of this goes
together to help make people
human and that's what we are trying to
do and
we are trying to be their new partner in
primary care
i like that and what does that actually
look like for you in practice
well it starts with an entire care team
from top to bottom
and we're all trained specifically to
work with seniors
and every aspect of our experience is
designed for seniors
beginning with the parking lot when they
pull in there's convenient parking
right in front of the building we have
nice wide lobby ways so wheelchairs can
get in people with walkers
so they have different ambulation needs
we also have longer visits we spend more
time with our patients
so we really get to know them and to get
to understand their needs
and their concerns and that's
keeping them socially engaged and
keeping us
as a team and a partner that's what
we're trying to do here
awesome and of course it is almost time
for annual enrollment period
let's break that down so people don't
lose their window
yeah actually we have a nice little
window this year and actually
it's from october 15th to december 7th
and open enrollment is when anybody over
the age of 65
can choose their health care plans or
change their health care plans and it's
a good time to re-evaluate your health
plan at this time
because 2021 is bringing different
things to us
in terms of needs and i think
at this point in time would be great for
seniors to look into medicare advantage
plans
and there we are here partners in
primary care is here to help you
navigate
in that search if you have any questions
i'm sure a lot of people need to
need to actually take their wellness
exams right well actually
wellness exams is something that's very
important a lot of people have been
putting them off because of the covid
situation
and it's a really good time to really
get a good handle on your health
before there's a problem a wellness exam
is just that
we look at preventative things to
prevent you from
needing to go to the hospital for simple
routine things we are offering
telehealth options for the patients you
can come in in person and see us
in person for more information call
partners in primary care at 702-623-3774
or visit
seniorfocuslasvegas.com